thanks a lot for the organizers for
having me here it's been a really fun
week I'm talking to lots of different
people so I'll start by continuing
talking about the hard sphere model that
Chris spoke about and then switch
halfway through and talk about the hard
core model so independent sets and
graphs
okay so I'll define the same model that
Chris defined but in D dimensions so I'm
gonna place alpha and spheres each of
volume one uniformly at random and the
torus of volume n conditioned on no
overlap so here alpha is this density
parameter I think Rho and Chris's talk
and I think the sort of amazing
mathematical question is is there a
phase transition in this model in some
dimension so this is not known
mathematically Chris talked about what
physicists believe in 2d I think in
higher dimensions maybe three to three
dimensions let's say people think there
is a phase transition but basically no
no mathematical techniques we know are
able to show that there is a phase
transition so this is a really exciting
mathematical challenge okay so what can
we say I'm not going to answer this
question today but maybe I'll give you
an idea so and for a nice background
reading on this model there's a survey
fun with hard spheres okay so what makes
it difficult for one you have infinitely
many ground states right you can let's
take your sphere packing in 3d or 2d you
can shift it any way you want as well as
the fact that ground states are not easy
to talk about so above three dimensions
we don't even know what the best sphere
packing is so I think these two
ingredients make trying to show a phase
transition difficult and one question is
can we say anything rigorous at high
densities in this model so Chris showed
you what you can say you can show fast
mixing or correlation decay at low
densities but is there anything
mathematically rigorous we can say at
high densities
so what I want to talk about is this
excluded volume so when I say excluded
volume I mean you take these spheres the
blue spheres of volume one which aren't
allowed to overlap and now double the
radii and this is the excluded volume
it's all the region and torus that
you're not allowed to put another center
of a new sphere and so the theme of my
talk will be how can you relate this the
expectation of this excluded volume to
alpha what's the partition function of a
model so here the partition function
we're going to take an alpha and or you
know whatever number of spheres we have
alpha n we're gonna take integrals over
this torus and the function we're
integrating is exactly just the
indicator function that all the centers
of all all centers are a distance at
least twice the radius of a single
sphere okay so this is the partition
function it's a big integral but what's
nice is if you know the random geometric
graph so you have some space let's say
it's the torus and you place endpoints
uniformly at random and form an edge
between them if the center there within
distance to R this is exactly the
probability this random geometric graph
has no edges so this is something that
sounds easy to calculate this is
something that sounds really hard so
obviously this is actually really hard
to calculate it's some exponentially
small probability and you wouldn't want
to know something about the rate
function but it really is just the
probability this graph is empty okay so
how can we reason about this I want to
define an event so the event will be ek
and this is just the event that after
you've placed K centers the pairwise
distance is at least two R and VK will
be the fraction of excluded volume so
divided by n take the volume of the
union of this these
red spheres around the center's so these
are just an event and random variable
and the partition function is the
probability of e alpha n so the
probability that you've placed alpha n
centers and they don't form any edges
and we can calculate this just by
conditioning so it's just the
probability that the first alpha n minus
one didn't form any edges and then
what's the probability the last last guy
avoids everything well it's one minus
this excluded volume fraction okay so
enough nothing so so fancy there so you
can write you and then you can just do
that again and again and write this as
this product where each time we're
looking at the excluded volume
conditioned on the fact that it's
actually the blue spheres in the picture
form the sphere packing okay that's nice
so here's a theorem that you can get
just by writing it that way
the partition function in this model or
the probability that random geometric
graph is empty is upper bounded by one
minus P to the Alpha and choose two when
alpha is small enough okay so why did I
write P that way this is the probability
that in the random geometric graph if
you just through two points they would
be joined so it's like the edge the edge
density in the random geometric graph
model the thing on the right is what the
probability of an empty graph would be
if you're in the air - rainy setting
when all edges were independent okay and
so at low densities somehow the the
completely independent case is actually
a real upper bound for the partition
function and the general case and so how
do you show this well just go back to
the previous slide look at the
successive conditionings and you'll see
what what you actually need to show to
show this is that the expected excluded
volume given that the blue centers are
non-overlapping is at least the expected
volume of these larger
Union of the larger balls if you didn't
condition on anything at all yeah and
I'll call this the rest of the talk
repulsion and equality okay and and that
actually sounds not so hard to show
right
so you're saying take a bunch of spheres
throw them independently a random look
at their volume of the Union do the same
thing but condition on the event that
the Centers are not too close hopefully
that goes up but I was only able to show
it when the density is small and I try
pretty hard I tried for I don't know
maybe a year to show it at all densities
it's not too hard if for one dimension
you can write this down and and this
inequality is true and obviously if you
let the dimension tend to infinity this
turns into an equality but okay so that
that's sort of where things stood until
I did a calculation with what I said I
did a calculation actually this thing
fails so yeah so it's a shock
so in dimension 24 this propulsion
inequality fails at some density so what
we're saying is if you condition on the
pairwise repulsion of the centers the
expected volume of their union can
decrease okay I'll tell you how to do
the calculation so here I use this to
get a bound on the partition function so
this is an upper bound on the
probability there's no edges so I need a
lower bound on the probability there's
no edges to contradict okay and you you
might notice 24 and that sounds a bit
strange there's a reason there's a
really good sphere packing in 24
dimensions it's somehow very unusually
good and so here's the lower bound on
the probability there's no edges so you
take a great sphere packing okay you
know with the centers and now you form a
little tiny ball around the center's
and you say okay what's the probability
that my alpha and centers fall uniquely
in one of these okay and then they can't
the center's have to be a distance at
least this area plus this area okay and
so that gives that in physics I think
that's called the cell model lower bound
or something but it's it's very easy to
compute it just depends on the density
of the packing and it in fact
contradicts this bound okay so something
something very strange is going on
question you mean the the the the
density bound so this is from the leech
lattice you mean who came up with it I
don't know it's for me it's just a
number okay but but anyway it fails and
so what I want to ask and talk about the
rest of the talk is what the heck is
going on for this to fail just the
inequality for the partition function
fair as well it's not just the repulsion
so the only thing I can check is that
the inequality for the partition
function fails that's easy to check but
that implies that at some lower
densities the other thing must fail the
other thing is very hard to compute your
conditioning on this hard sphere
interaction so I have no idea how to
compute that okay so here here's the
only the only explanation I can come up
with involves you know at a high enough
density you're sort of forced into a
lattice like state and then there's like
these Swiss cheese gaps and this is
what's decreasing the excluded volume so
here's a conjecture for you if you're in
the fluid phase and let's say you have
exponential decay of correlations or
however you define it then the repulsion
inequality should hold okay so if you're
somehow in the nice state where
everything is decaying
I would conjecture that your intuition
should hold
and this would imply a phase transition
in dimension 24 okay so any questions
this is that's the last I'll say about
spheres okay
so let's let's go to graphs yeah so what
so what I would mean would be you have
have exponential decay of correlations
and then you don't anymore yeah so
however you define it then show that it
in the fluid phase this thing holds we
did an easy calculation to show it fails
at some point so whatever you whatever
your assumption was to show it holds
that's that's the conjecture yeah so the
conjecture would be show that
exponential decay implies the repulsion
inequality and I guess the strategy is
instead of trying to say something
difficult in the high density phase I
just showed something very easy in the
high density phase and the remaining
ingredient would be to show something
very strong but in the fluid phase which
seems like more within our grasp to do
okay so let's go to graphs now and talk
about the hard core model so you've seen
this several times already we'll take a
graph for me it will be D regular and
we'll pick an independent set with
probability proportional to lambda to
the size of the independent set and here
Z is the partition function that some
lambda the I over all independent sets
of G and what I want to talk about is
something called the occupancy fraction
you've seen this actually even in
Leslie's first talk she talked about
this but it's the average probability
that a vertex is in the independent set
so it's the average over these vertices
you can also actually write this as a
derivative of the partition function so
it's the normalized logarithmic
derivative of the partition function and
so besides switching from continuous to
discrete you also notice I switched from
the canonical model where we fixed the
number of particles to the grand
canonical where we have lambda and so
whereas before it was I wanted to look
at the relationship between the density
and the excluded volume fraction now I
want to look at the relationship between
lambda and alpha so between lambda and
the occupancy fraction and somehow play
with this to try to understand the model
better okay so one thing is that if you
want to bound the the free-energy the
log of the partition function you can
bound the occupancy fraction because you
can just integrate and so this was used
by dem beaumont inari and sana at least
for one example i know for factor models
on locally tree like graphs i'm gonna
show you a application of doing this in
combinatorics a side question is is
there any algorithmic application of
doing this so trying to attack alpha
instead of bounding a partition function
here's the application of alpha it's a
common notorious so here's the theorem
of Jeff Kahn David Galvin prasad and you
fail i'll tell you each part but the the
theorem says if you look at any d
regular graph G then the normalized
partition function is upper bounded by
that of k DD so that's the complete
bipartite graph D vertices on each side
with all the edges so Jeff can prove
this for just the number of independent
sets and under the restriction G is
bipartite Dalvin totally showed actually
this works for any homomorphism not just
for independent sets but still bipartite
g and then you phase ow
showed a reduction from the general case
to bipartite and this is a combinatorial
proof about counting homo homo morphisms
using something called the entropy
method
so what I want to show you is a new
theorem and this is with human Davies
Matthew Jensen and Barnaby Roberts in
London
they're got students at LSE and our
theorem is actually the occupancy
fraction is upper bounded by that of KT
D so again this is trying to use the
relationship between alpha and lambda to
prove something about the partition
function so it's a short proof all I'll
show you it right now but so this is a
strengthening of the theorem above
because you can just integrate this
theorem to get that theorem and it's
probabilistic and that we stay in the
hard core model and prove everything in
the hard core model okay so we have our
graph its triangle assume it's D regular
for now assume it's triangle free and I
just want to say a couple facts about
the hard core model so first the
definition we'll call a vertex uncovered
if none of its neighbors are in the
independent set so nothing's preventing
it from being in the independent set it
could be in the independent set it might
not be so two facts so the conditional
probability that a vertex is in the
independent set given that it's
uncovered is lambda over 1 plus lambda I
guess the Markov property of the model
and then the probability that a vertex
is uncovered given that it has j
uncovered neighbors is exactly 1 plus
lambda to the minus J and here's where
we use the fact that it's triangle free
so if we were doing the proof for not
triangle free way to have some partition
function of a neighborhood right there
okay but those are the two facts I'll
need for the proof so I'll give you the
proof now so alpha is 1 over n sum over
the vertices probability that V is in
the independent set this is by fact 1
lambda over 1 plus
although he is uncovered
and that's fact one fact - now we're
gonna condition on the number of
uncovered neighbors over J equals zero
to D probably V has J uncovered
neighbors 1 plus lambda to the minus J
okay so still everything's in equality
you know you don't we don't know
anything about these probabilities that
could be hard to calculate I want to
define a random variable to be the
number of uncovered neighbors of a
uniformly random vertex in the graph so
two layers of randomness you're picking
your random independent set according to
the hardcore model you're picking a
random vertex uniformly and why is just
this count so it's somewhere between
zero and D and integer and if you see
what I've written here I've it's just
notation what I've written is lambda
over 1 plus lambda times the expectation
of 1 plus lambda to the - why
that's that's just an equality now I
want to just calculate the expectation
of Y itself this is 1 over n sum over
the vertices now some of our neighbors
of a vertex probability that u is
uncovered ok so now it's d regular so
each u appears in the sum the double sum
D times so this equals D times 1 over n
sum over u probability you uncovered
okay and then then we can just look up
here that sum is 1 plus lambda over
lambda times alpha
so I've written inequality two
equalities one involving the expectation
of this exponential and one involving
the expectation of Y and this is just an
identity for all D regular graphs okay
so in the hardcore model any D regular
graph any lambda this is just an
identity and again the the knowing the
distribution of Y is hard who knows what
the distribution of Y is but this is
true and now the proof is just a line so
if we relax the optimization problem now
to just all random variables between 0
and D that satisfy this equation just by
convexity you want to put all the mass
on 0 and D ok and there's a unique such
distribution so in the relaxed problem
the Maximizer supported 0 and D and
there's a unique such distribution that
supported on 0 and D and that satisfies
this ok now now look at our graph kdd
you look at some vertex let's say a
vertex here how many of its neighbors
are uncovered well if any guy here is in
the independent set and the answer is 0
and if no guys here are in the
independent set then D so this
distribution has support 0 in D there's
a unique one that's the Maximizer and so
the kdd maximizes alpha and that's the
proof
yeah so you want to maximize alpha so
yeah it's it's some you know one over G
times land over one plus lambda times
that yeah yeah so it's a completely
probabilistic very short proof of this
stronger statement okay any questions
about the yep good good question
okay so with the exact same I think
maybe I say on the next slide okay with
the exact same proof but with one one
more assumption okay
so now now assume that G is bipartite
and transitive just vertex-transitive a
graph okay every you know there there's
a graph whatever that sends every vertex
to every vertex so if you assume that
then what you can show is that the
occupancy fraction is greater than that
of the unique translation invariant
measure on the infinite D regular tree
and actually you know it is almost
exactly the same proof one way to think
of it is if you condition on a vertex
not being in the independent set and
then you look at the indicator indicator
random variables that its neighbors are
uncovered the most correlated you can be
is have these guys be identical
that's kdd the the least correlated you
can be is to have them sum to a constant
that's a different theorem but if if
you're in a bipartite graph then
actually they have to be positively
correlated and so the least positively
correlated you can be is if these
indicator random variables are
independent and then independence is the
relation you would get for the infinite
tree
the restriction so triangle free for the
upper bound we get rid of it's easy to
get rid of I mean the proof is just it
would take five more lines but it's it's
the same for obviously for this for for
lower bounds you need some condition you
need triangle free condition to get
anything okay but right so the this
proof comes and this is somehow more
related probably to white people in the
audience are interested in this
translation invariant hardcore measure
so here's a question I have no idea that
answer to so if lambda is less than the
critical lambda on the tree then somehow
this bound is asymptotically achievable
just take a random D regular bipartite
graph but above lambda C I have no idea
what the minimizer should be and I know
actually it's not always the random D
regular bipartite graph so you know if I
give you a lambda that's above lambda C
which graph minimizes this occupancy
fraction I have no idea it would be
interesting to know
so back back to where we started this
repulsion and equality you can you can
set up the repulsion inequality in this
model too and it's pretty nice so I'll
say the repulsion inequality and for a D
regular graph the Hardcore model you
know in the fugacities model is that
alpha divided by lambda should be less
than or equal to e to the minus D plus 1
times alpha okay and now I'll give you
the interpretation the interpretation is
this let's say you wanted to calculate
the expected free volume of the model so
free volume means vertices that are
neither in the independent set nor have
a neighbor that's exactly alpha over
lambda okay so if you remember the fact
one was the probability you're in the
independent set given that your
uncovered is lambda over 1 plus lambda
so uncovered is occupied plus free and
so free is exacta fraction of free is
exactly alpha over lambda and then on
the right it's what the expected
fraction of free volume would be if
everything was like a nice independent
Poisson process so imagine each each
vertex gets plus on alpha number of
occupied particles then the probability
that you're free is a probability that
you and all your neighbors of D plus 1
sites none of them get one of these plus
on particles and so that's e to the
minus D plus 1 alpha so that's the
interpretation ok so what types of
things are true so for all graphs and
small enough lambda this is true for
bipartite graphs it fails let's say D is
at least 6 then it fails already at
lambdas on the order of 1 over D for the
tree the infinite tree it always holds
for the translation invariant measure ok
and then if you look at the semi
translation invariant measure so this is
this is the measure on the tree you
would get above criticality by looking
at a high even depth say and
conditioning on all these particles
being occupied
so then you'll have depending on if the
root is even or odd you'll have two
different occupancy fractions so I'm a
virgin them and so this inequality fails
and the point at which it fails the
ratio of that to the critical lambda
tends to 1 as d goes to infinity so at
least on the tree this the failure of
this inequality is identifying the phase
transition I thought that was
interesting so yeah so I'm always
thinking regular graphs and then small
enough will be some function of D like
maybe 1 over d squared I think ok so I
want to talk about one other model but
I'm really not introducing a new model
the monomer dimer model so this is a
random matching in a graph with the
probability of a particular matching
weighted by lambda 2 the size of the
matching this is just the hard core
model on the line graph of a graph so
line graph is where you switch vertices
and edges so think of this as a hard
core model and then you can also define
the the matching occupancy fraction so
that I mean there's a reason I'm
introducing this after the repulsion
inequality so here's another theorem in
our paper is that this matching
occupancy fraction is upper bounded by
that of the complete deregulate
bipartite graph and the proof is longer
we actually have to set up a linear
program with D constraints where D is
you know D we want to show it for all D
and we have to solve the linear program
but it works and it's roughly the same
idea the first corollary of this is that
the partition function is maximized so
this wasn't known in the previous case
this was known the con galvan totally
zhao theorem
so in this case that was a conjecture
it's somehow a generalization of bregman
theorem so bregman theorem says a
collection of complete bipartite graphs
maximizes the number of perfect
matchings and we're saying this matching
partition function is maximized by this
graph so that's that's one corollary the
other may be more also interesting is
that this repulsion inequality always
holds in the monomer dimer model so
which is nice because we also know that
there's no phase transition and the
monomer dimer model so it still fits
this fits it with this intuition that if
you're in the fluid phase what you know
or intuition about the repulsion thing
should hold
and so here's a conjecture CD so I would
I would conjecture that in ZD if you're
in the fluid phase so against a
exponential decay of correlations that
this repulsion inequality always holds
okay and so here of course D means two
different things it means dimension or
regularity but this Z D is 2 D regular
so that's why there's the 2 D there so
this is the conjecture it's the exact
analog of the conjecture I gave for the
spheres it would imply the optimal bound
on the critical point of 1 over D order
1 over D so what's known now is 0 minus
1/3 and I did look I I would like to be
contradicted about this you know so I
don't keep trying to trying to show it
but I looked at the physics papers and
saw what they predict the different
values are for lambda C on you know this
is Z 2 Z 3 Z 4 z 5 z 6 and what they've
calculated the occupancy fraction at
criticality and then the third line I've
just computed the ratio of the
right-hand side to the left-hand side
and this repulsion and equality and so
at least for up to 6 it seems like it
holds it criticality and it does show
there's something different about two
dimensions so so it really really holds
in two dimensions and then it's getting
closer and closer to being tight as
dimension is going up I mean this is
just just numerical simulations but yeah
so I did
I guess the conjecture is proposing a
method to show a phase transition that's
I think different than the usual method
about counting paths you know counting
boundaries and stuff like this I think
the nice thing about it is if if it's
somehow able to work it doesn't rely at
all on the you know the number of ground
States being - doesn't rely on by part
tightness so one model here and this is
another nice challenge besides the hard
sphere model take Z D
and add ml the diagonal edges and then
do the hardcore model on this this is
not known to have a phase transition I
mean you've ruined by part tightness you
have many many ground states and so how
do you show a phase transition in this
model so I think it's it's a good
challenge to try to find some techniques
for getting at a phase transition that
don't depend on bipartite nests or a
small number of ground stacks so I'm
really looking for counter examples to
prove me wrong
so I checked that and there the
repulsion inequality always holds and so
again this is my intuition is in 2d both
in this the disk case and in the any 2d
model on the lattice I think it should
always hold and so in that case it
always holds yeah so that's
unfortunately not a counter example but
yeah
okay well thanks ray
very interesting too